et
on va plus loin avec à mes côtés comme
chaque jeudi l'historien françois
durpaire bonjour françois rouge ou
raphaël et bilal tard avec la rédaction
de france 24 bilal bonjour à faire les
états unis montent en puissance dans la
guerre en ukraine où washington va
livrer pour 800 millions de dollars
d'armements offensifs à l'armée
ukrainienne écoutez le porte parole du
pentagone
le budget de votre famille un plein
d'essence rien de cela ne devrait
dépendre d'un dictateur qui déclare la
guerre et commet un génocide à l'autre
bout du monde citoyens alors là on n'est
pas effectivement sur les livraisons
d'armements on est sur le génocide est
ce qu'on a jack kirby et donc qui john
kirby pardon qui évoque la question des
livraisons d'armes en régie
aujourd'hui le président a annoncé est
autorisé une nouvelle aide à la sécurité
de l'ukraine d'une valeur pouvant
atteindre 800 millions de dollars
elle est adaptée pour répondre aux
besoins craignent un urgent pour le
combat d'aujourd'hui alors que les
forces russes se concentrent désormais à
l'est dans leur agression impitoyable de
l'ukraine
a concrètement un des blindés des obus
des canons des drones des missiles anti
chars ainsi que des pièces tartié de
dernière génération utilisent encore
récemment 9 ghani selon ce qu'on appelle
plus prosaïquement des armes l'autre
françois durpaire jusqu'ici les états
unis s'y était refusé pour ne pas passer
pour des co belligérance est donc
désormais washington ne craint plus la
réaction du kremlin alors c'est pas
évident qu'on passe de livraisons
d'armes défensives à des liserés dont
d'armes offensives c'est pas très clair
quand on prend la liste en fait des
armements déjà livré à l'ukraine on
avait sept mille fusil d'assaut ce que
c'est des suicides à flot défensif ou
offensif on avait 50 millions de balles
de munitions aux pareil là on annonce
800 millions il faut rappeler quand même
qu'on a eu quand même déjà 2 milliards
400 millions qui ont été données aux
ukrainiens ce sont bien des soldats
ukrainien qui résistent mais avec des
armes américaines et depuis le début
donc en fait la question c
les américains deviennent déco
belligérants à partir du moment où ils
communiquent sur le fait qu'il donne des
armes à partir du moment où ces
livraisons d'armes deviennent moins
discrète qu'elle l'était auparavant car
c'est le cas aujourd'hui alors c'est le
cas aujourd'hui je rappelle quand même
que resnick enfin le ministre ukrainien
de la défense jusqu'à au déclenchement
de la guerre jusqu'à l'invasion russe
s'étaient tous les jours des tweets qui
se féliciter des livraisons d'armes
américaines c'est formidable sixième
avion est arrivé avec ses armes alors il
y avait d'ailleurs des photos sais pas
si vous vous souvenez de réception de
ces armes américain
plus aucune depuis l'invasion russe est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya plus aucune
d'ailleurs la discrétion américaine est
le pendant également de la discrétion
russe des deux côtés on avait intérêt à
dire il se passe rien de ce côté là
aujourd'hui c'est en train de changer de
toute évidence joe biden le deal annonce
nous sommes aux côtés des ukrainiens il
s'en va voir effectivement moins peur de
la réaction de vladimir poutine des
armes que réclamait désespérément un
volodymyr zelensky le président
ukrainien bilai ça va changer quoi
concrètement ça alors on le sait l'armée
russe est en train de se replier sur
lèze sur le dombass là où en fait
l'armée ukrainienne là enfin la partie
de l'armée ukrainienne la plus aguerrie
et présente de 1000 cas depuis 2014 et
donc avec tous les systèmes défensifs
qui s'en suivent puisque 2014 doit ya ça
fait huit ans
alors zelensky demandait césar mais
évidemment ce que ça peut changer c'est
augmenter la capacité de résistance de
l'armée ukrainienne je donne juste
quelques exemples dans les dernières
livraisons annoncées dont on n'a pas
totalement le détail mais on a des des
canons de fabrication britannique par
exemple ils s'appellent des sondés m 777
au leader alors sont considérés comme
des canons léger je mets légers entre
guillemets parce que ça reste des canons
qui sont manoeuvrés voiliers sont
plantés sur le sol ya neuf personnes
autour ça envoie des obus de 15 cm de
diamètre à 50 km de distance clairement
ces deux de l'armement si vous voulez
pour résister à un siège vous pour
contrer un autre siège on a des drones
qu'on appelle switchblade ça ce sont des
drones qui sont contre en sport tas en
sac à dos à pied par l'infanterie et
qu'on appelle des drones kamikaze c'est
à dire qu'on peut les envoyer comme ça
presque comme des avions planeurs
s'écraser sur l'ennemi pareil à une
distance entre eux entre 10 et 40 km ce
qui pour de la contre-offensive en fait
est idéale donc ce que ça va changer oui
c'est ça maintenant françois le disait
très justement les américains livrent
déjà des armes alors on peut parler d
javeline qui ont été terribles pour les
chars russes on considère que les
l'armée russe a perdu 10% de ses chars
en ukraine les jablines je le rappelle
tout à fait des missiles anti chars de
fabrication américaine qui sont un peu
en classique du format guérilla à côté
de la kalachnikov que c'est un tube
qu'on transporte à l'épaule on l'envoie
il verrouille automatiquement sa cible
terminé on passe à autre chose donc
c'est jablines était déjà livré les
missiles stinger sol air c'est pareil et
puis surtout il faudrait quand même
parler des drones turc berrada rarement
parler mais c'est le risque pas d'
internationaliser le conflit nous après
vous c'est quand même un c'est quand
même une étape supplémentaire c'est une
gradation dans dans la guerre
internationalisation et risque de
dérapage imaginons maintenant que il est
clair que joe biden dit nous cessons la
distinction entre les armements défense
effet les armements offensifs
on peut tout à fait imaginer vladimir
poutine se disant voilà ce qu'on voit
c'est un convoi américain convoi
occidental qui vient aider la résistance
et craignait et bien je le bombarde les
ce qui se passe dans ce cas là qu'est ce
qui se passe si on bat si les russes
bumba un convoi si le bombarde en
ukraine ou s'il le bombarde or de
l'ukraine c'est encore pire évidemment
et puis alors degré de complexité
supplémentaire là aujourd'hui par
exemple la russie accusé l'ukraine
d'avoir bombardé des villages à sa
frontière côté russe s'il s'agit
effectivement d'armements fournis par
les occidentaux est ce que là il n'ya
pas aussi villa risque d'être considérée
comme là encore partie prenante de ce
conflit alors franchement si tant est
que c'est vrai et citant tech c'est le
scénario que vous décrivez en fait
finalement le la réponse elle appartient
à moscou à partir de quel moment donc
pour la russie ou pas la russie de toute
manière le choix il est simple à un
moment donné c'est soit affronté l'armée
ukrainienne soit affronter les armées de
l'otan tout en même temps parce qu'on va
pas revenir sur les assure comment
fonctionne le temps avec les dommages
causés par l'armée crédit dont moscou va
à la aujourd'hui le navire amiral de la
de la flotte russe en mer noire est ce
qu'il ne faut pas s'attendre françois ce
que la russie considère aussi un moment
l'occident voilà comme responsable
d'avoir un mais les ukrainiens
finalement parce que au-delà même du du
dommage en tant que tel il ya le les les
effets directs sur l'image de la russie
dans ce qu'on fait et ça donne également
des arguments à vladimir poutine pour
son opinion publique c'est une manière
de dire à son opinion publique je vous
ai depuis le départ raconté je vous ai
fait le récit d'un occident agressif
regardé le discours de joe biden qui dit
une ce sont des armes offensives livrer
à ces ukrainiens nazis donc on parlait
du soutien de vladimir poutine d'anti
bénéficié de la part de sa population et
de la part de ces fameux oligarques qui
beaucoup maintenant on ne voient leur
avenir qu'en russie ça va évidemment
mettre de l'eau à son moulin non un mot
rapide un minuscule mans en fait les
missiles que l'ukraine revendique
d'avoir lancé sur le navire sont des
missiles pour le coup ukrainien et
ironie du sort il s'agit de missiles
russes modifié par les ukrainiens vont
elles n'y a pas de risque d'accusation à
la fois ci pour les occidentaux les
etats-unis alors on l'écouté on va leur
écoute et qui n'hésite pas aussi à
qualifié l'offensive russe en ukraine le
génocide écouter joe biden
le budget de votre famille un plein
d'essence
rien de cela ne devrait dépendre d'un
dictateur qui déclare la guerre et
commet un génocide à l'autre bout du
monde un terme un génocide qu emmanuel
macron lui se refuse pour leurs employés
au grand désespoir du président
ukrainien puisque le parlement en
ukraine a d'ailleurs voté aujourd'hui
une résolution qui qui parle de génocide
françois durpaire on a affaire là une
simple querelle sémantique ou bien c'est
plus grave que ça et qui dit vrai du
coup alors le terme horse ce que vous
invitez un historien j'ai forcément
faire un tout petit peu d'histoire sur
le terme de génocide ce terme de
génocide il a été défini en 1943 par
raphael lemkin et raphael lemkin son
idée qui était qui était un juriste
polonais professeur de droit
disait il faut un terme pour désigner
plus qu un ethnocide c'est la
destruction systématique d'un peuple et
attentionnel mais très rapidement eh
bien il ya eu une polémique autour de ce
terme et on a un autre professeur de
droit qui s'appelle le tord bâche qui
lui à rénover le concept de crimes
contre l'humanité et pourquoi il dit ça
parce qu'il dit à partir du moment où on
perd on utilise le terme de génocide
et bien si vous voulez le risque c'est
que ce soit groupe contre groupe
legris la victime c'est un groupe et les
bourreaux baisse est un groupe et ça le
torba qui dit non la racine du droit
c'est l'individu envoyer c'est quand
même assez simple à comprendre et c'est
pour ça que contrairement à ce que
certains peuvent penser le terme de
génocide est exclu de du fameux tribunal
de nuremberg gh qui ne retient que le
crime contre l'humanité ce n'est pas un
chef d'accusation
donc c'est quand même ça va quand même
au delà des mots dire un génocide pour
vous donner un exemple aujourd'hui on a
une
définition assez large de ce terme du
côté américain puisque il y a trois
semaines déjà joe biden utilise ce terme
de génocide pour qualifier les actes de
l'armée bergame berman contre les
rohingya mais il s'agit quand même de
créer une co mis en 2016 en 2017 ça veut
dire que là on a une accélération de
l'usaj de ce mot et joe biden en quelque
sorte c'était le premier à avoir utilisé
au sein de la maison blanche celui de
criminels de guerre vous rappeler que
blinken le secrétaire d'état ou jack
sullivan qui lui est à la tête du
conseil national de sécurité
hésité à utiliser ce terme ce n'est pas
une simple quelle ville s'est passé à
crimes de guerre ça correspond là aussi
une notion juridique exactement et et
alors you buy donne tout le temps dit
attention jeu il y aura des juristes
internationaux je suis pas un juriste
mais il ya quand même une série de
critiques alors les critiques de droite
notamment alors les trump et ski di c
notre oncle fou qui lors d'un dîner
d'ailleurs de quoi by donne et qui va
entraîner les états unis dans un conflit
dans une troisième guerre mondiale
contre poutine mais il ya des réflexions
quand même plus j'allais dire un peu
plus mesuré
consistant à dire mais oui mais si on a
une définition élargie du terme de
génocide
quid de nous les américains quid de
l'invasion d'irak quid du bombardement
de la libye
quid de ce que fait l'arabie saoudite au
yémen donc ça a des conséquences
d'élargir à ce point le terme de
génocide à ce qui est incontestablement
des atrocités mais là pour le coup le
mot atrocités pose aucun problème dans
la presse américaine le terme de
génocide c'est évidemment beaucoup plus
complexe et oui parce que derrière ces
termes ça recouvre effectivement demain
de possible condamnation à saran
finalement les dirigeants russes
justiciables devant la justice
internationale c'est à dire la cpi bilal
tarabet pas tout à fait déjà on rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui
ce jeudi le parlement ukrainien a voté
une résolution pour déjà qualifié ce que
fait la russie en ukraine de génocide
mais c'est une résolution pardon qui
aussi demande à toutes les autres
institutions qu'elles soient
internationales et multilatérales comme
l'otan les nations unies ou qu'elles
soient nationales comme les parlements
de pays divers et variés de eux aussi
qualifiés ce que fait la russie de
génocide et bien sûr ça impliquerait que
le pouvoir russe les donneurs d'ordres
quel qu'il soit et si jamais un jour ils
sont identifiés déterminés doivent
rendre des comptes mais ça là dessus
quand même je rejoins c'est très
important ce que ce que disait françois
parce que crime contre l'humanité est
une notion juridique bien baliser le
crime de guerre aussi le génocide il a
une part de subjectivité parce que en
fait c'est dans sa jurisprudence avoir
une intention la volonté d'éradiquer
agrément aux motifs d'une ethnie d'une
religion d'un terrain et donne projets
tels faits on pense à la radio des mille
collines on pense aux écrits d'adolf
hitler etc on pense au génocide arménien
s'ils sont les trois génocides dans
l'histoire je laissais d'art medien
qu'elle aussi des tutsis et génocide
juif qu'ils sont mais c'est important
sera la pose la question des preuves
donc sa porte la question des preuves ça
pose à nous prouver l'intention
délibérée des nominations d'un passé
pour ça que le mot c'est pour ça que
d'abord les biden l'a dit en passant
c'était pas ça l'objet de son discours
il était en train de parler d'autre
chose de la facture énergétique et les
américains c'est une maladresse et ce
qu'il a dévoyé ce terme alors à des fins
politiques certains il ya deux options
soit effectivement il dit ça en passant
alors les journalistes américains bon
c'est ici en europe visiblement c'est
grave de penser manuel macro et en
version qu'il a dévoyé le journaliste
américain ensuite leur pose la question
un peu comme un vieillard qui l'on se
dise qu'il est vraiment est ce qu'il a
vraiment dit ça et il l'a redit et la
mer explicite et juridiquement il ya une
intention et une intention notamment de
nier l'existence même des ukrainiens
donc ça veut dire qui sait ce que ça
veut dire juridiquement joe biden
506 il ya des juristes qui disent les
russes n'avaient pas d'intentions
délibéré d'éradiquer la population
guinéenne ce qu'on peut dire ici
varierait pas d'un des querelles de
juristes est en train d'expliquer de la
politique ses passions à joe biden
utilise ce terme
si c'est pas des gars sénile qui disent
n'importe quoi mais quelqu'un qui a des
intentions politiques qui était que
celui de la première puissance du monde
il a des intentions et ses intentions
c'est quoi c'est que c'est ce que les
américains sont pas en train de passer
du but de guerre sauver l'ukraine au but
de guerre se débarrasser de poutine
parce que comment imaginer aujourd'hui
de négocier avec un boucher un criminel
de guerre quelqu'un qui parce que
l'important ce n'est pas le génocide
c'est le génocidaire c'est le leader
génocidaire et ça ça paraît quand même
très compliqué devient fréquentable il
n'est pas nouveau il est devant une cour
mais papa dans une discussion et penser
aux ukrainiens parce que ce qui est
important c'est que emmanuel macron dit
non nous on n'utilise pas ce terme parce
qu'ils pensent à la presse et vlady
moitié les inscrits ils s'engouffrent là
dedans et certains se disaient ce que
les ukrainiens sont pas du fait de ce
terme il se transforme non pas en
résistant mais en victime ce qui est
plus du tout la même chose dans un
combat ce qui est plus du tout la même
chose d'ailleurs pour le devoir de
mémoire des ukrainiens être résistant
aux victimes la vaillance ou la
vulnérabilité
ça pose des problèmes qui sont
considérables j'allais dire que là il
s'est engouffré dans quelque chose le
président eh oui et il nous reste une
minute bilal tarbes et ce faisant est ce
que il ne rend pas la tâche impossible
aux ukrainiens eux mêmes joe biden en
coupant effectivement toute possibilité
de réconciliation
demain avec la russie en gros le combat
pour les ukrainiens c'est triompher ou
être éradiqué
abat clairement en tout cas il ya toute
une toute une rhétorique un tout une
sémantique dans ce conflit depuis le
départ qui commence à devenir
incompréhensible c'est à dire que
vladimir poutine envahi l'ukraine pour
motif d'un gène de son motif de vouloir
prévenir et empêcher un pardon un soi
disant génocide dans le donbass contre
les russophones d'une autre les
russophones du don base désormais c'est
le camp ukraino américain appelons ça
comme ça qu'ils accusent en retour
vladimir poutine de génocide donc c'est
peut-être contre-productif dans le sens
où ça use peut-être cette escalade
verbale rend le rend l'analyse rend les
choses un peu incompréhensible et oui
alors la géographie avec la première
étape vous rappelez il ya des mois joe
biden était l'homme qui n'était pas dans
la gradation verbale qui résistait ainsi
qu'aux vladimir poutine à l'époque
disait une simple incursion il avait
évoqué ce lieu était suffisamment
reproché d'ailleurs merci beaucoup
françois durpaire merci bilal tarabet on
va plus loin c'est terminé on se
retrouve dans trois minutes dans paris
direct
[Musique]